police run as a building collapses in
the city of malathia in Eastern Turkey
dozens of buildings were destroyed even
though the epicenter was 10 kilometers
away
many already badly damaged by the twin
earthquakes on February 6. at least 30
people were rescued from underneath the
rubble
excavators and emergency teams were
trying desperately to rescue people
suspected to be trapped under the rubble
authorities say they received
information there were three more people
inside when the building collapsed
but they told Al Jazeera they're not
hearing any voices
just a few meters away Cutter's friend
was caught inside another building when
he went to pick up some of his
belongings
he was helping his friend who wanted to
enter the house to pick up some of his
belongings now he is under trouble
he was with a friend who was rescued 45
minutes after the earthquake happened
rescue workers are now trying to get him
out
we just arrived here and we believe
there is one person who is still alive
officials say that aftershocks and
earthquakes like this could last for at
least a year leaving people in this part
of turkey on the edge
this country is still struggling to
recover from the earthquakes that
happened three weeks ago that left over
40 000 people dead and hundreds of
thousands of people without a home this
earthquake generates tension anguish and
lots and lots of fear
turkey